hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to grab the bottle now this
game is absolutely bizarre if it is 100%
weird but that doesn't mean that I'm not
on board with the concept because you'll
see why it's weird
very soon oh don't you worry oh don't
you worry huh
that baby looks so oh ho that baby looks
ancient your goal is to get the bottle
and grab it start the game by pressing
grab a maneuver to the bottle avoid
hitting anything on the way you have to
hit points rush grab to continue grab it
oh that ain't right
that ain't right that boy right oh that
boy ain't right oh that boy is every
kind of weird rip armed I knew one I
mean I guess you don't have any problem
growing the longest warm in the world
baby
do not laugh at me like that you freaky
baby [ __ ] you need to collect all the
collectables before grabbing the bottle
is that a requirement here we go oh it's
like catch your chance but somehow
infinitely weirder oh man it's like mrs.
Incredibles other baby
do not laugh at me like that you freaky
baby is that big round objects with the
blue outline can be pushed forward by
ramming your and automa yeah if you can
even call that your hand sure let's go
with ramming or I fine I'm whatever with
this where is there towel fluttering in
the wind
alright whatever oops well that's not
what I want Wow
alright oh oh my [ __ ] hand got
explode all of my baby bones got
shattered on impact okay so I think I
need to come in from the other angle
here
well that didn't work at all
hang on wait hang on I got it all right
it's like playing slither slither Aereo
it's supposed to do that oh man this is
this is a doozy yeah it's like slow very
Oh or slither I Oh is everyone else in
the world cause it but not me oh I was
trying to get back I just need to get
over to the bottle over there and then
all right okay I get it now I was being
dumb just shattering my baby bones on
everything here often you need to grab
and pull objects with a blue glow to
solve puzzles press and hold the grab to
start pulling back drop the item by
letting go of the button all right sure
I'm not sure I remember what the grab
button was oh it works like that now
does it okay
all right I'd hate to meet the parents
of this baby here we go who's with the
breathing what were you getting
impatient baby no that's not what I
wanted oh I know what I need to do okay
so what I need to do is I need to get
over here yeah yeah that's the stuff
[Applause]
hahahaha ah yes mother do you need help
cleaning underneath the couch could lend
you a hand
ha ha ha so [ __ ] up I love it well so
we set a bottle of piss in the bottom
right now whatever we're gonna gloss
over that fact some objects break down
when dropped be careful about when where
you drop them no I was coming from that
angle I'm sorry
excuse you I gotta make a bit of a
journey over here because we've got to
do a whole bunch of [ __ ] for some
reason excuse me while I exact my
revenge on my broken hand by dropping
one of mother's precious items SCU's
SCU's also how do I have the strength
how do I have the sheer manipulative
strength as a baby to pick this [ __ ] up
in the first place oh my god that's my
that's my point of contention in this
like I don't like the logic of that Oh
Frick I forgot no I forgot I forgot to
get the first one in the first place cam
yeah I forgot about that yeah okay
alright yeah right I'm gonna get that
first you know for being a freakish game
from hell is oddly relaxing like the
music is nice and it's a soothing smooth
snake like penile motion you know I
think I can get behind this game and I
get behind I mean throw it down into the
deepest hole and bury it forever and
then toss it into the pits of hell so
that it can burn for all eternity and
I'll sacrifice it to the various gods or
it'll say this few more times it's fun
baby that baby is not okay something
horrible going on you know what
something is supposed to look normal and
you know it's supposed to be like masked
by the niceties of oh the ding dong
xylophone but then you forget there's a
[ __ ] baby here grabbin clamps and
and somehow he's able to see this so
that means he's got like eyeballs in his
arm ready with what oh my god I didn't
read what I was supposed to do with that
I don't know what I'm supposed to do I
guess I'm supposed to grab this I'll
grab it oh ouch cabals oh that's what
that do oh that's what that do [ __ ] well
this ain't gonna go well okay well I
mean oh jeez
yeah this ain't gonna go well yeah this
ain't gonna go well let's just soar into
death slap myself in my own face oh okay
so I was being a smartypants about this
doll [ __ ] you can't make that turn okay
so you can't do that so you have to do
it in a certain order that's what I'm
discovering here you have to do this
first show ink and then you have to pull
the other one and let me go down here to
pull this one Zoop okay oh but I got it
and then with my slightly oh no I forgot
about that one bottle soft alright fine
last time we got this one I don't know
what this is but really okay yeah I
pulled this back before and it didn't
seem to do nothing so I'm just assuming
it does nothing oh okay well that was
really really really close quarters I
still don't think it's gonna matter
cuz if I can't get through here no I can
cycle around I just can't get my poor
baby hand broken again
I don't think ye I don't think that was
the way that I was supposed to do it but
I did it okay
ah [ __ ] dude why was that so hard
that was like obscenely difficult that
was like ridiculously Danka fault I died
21 times on
it's an embarrassment let me see if I
can do better on the next one just do it
redeem myself I mean you didn't see all
the horrible Hornets that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] ready
I don't know rabbit all right well
baby's coiling around his own gosh darn
thing air dope no no I'm trying to do
what oh the bottles in the castle is it
oh oh oh
[Music]
Oh Oh
so you got to go for this one first no
no no still see yeah how do you do that
okay I think I know how it's just like
it really does it really just wants you
to do very very very precise tolerances
here [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah can't
even make it out of my own basket what
does she grab it if you want it just
grab it it's right there no one's
stopping you here we go real tight real
tight on this real tight oh yeah Oh am I
gonna be able to get back I don't know
you were gonna find out ye tight tight
tight Jesus oh jeez oh [ __ ] squeeze
tight squish squish squish mmm Church
quiz okay
tight squeeze tight squeeze okay okay
all right okay ah I guess they didn't
want to make it easy they really didn't
oh my god okay precision is apart is
being away I think that's all I'm gonna
play of this particular game here it is
weird it is funky
but I kind of like it if you're into
this sort of puzzle aspect thing going
that they got going on here oh my god I
don't want to go to Grandma's I don't
want to go so anyway vanities are all
for grab the bottle thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know if I
this down the comments below because
this is a weird one but this might
appeal to some of you guys so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]